Hello Freak bitches.
Oh,
this is a period where I was doing a lot of psychedelics and one of the
experiences you've probably had on psychedelics is the,
the amazing experience of just looking into someone's eyes on acid or mushrooms
and just having that just open a kind of inner landscape of profundity you're
seeming profundity where you're just,
you know,
you can just be staring into someone's eyes silently for an eternity or what
seems like an eternity.
And um,
what often happens to people is that after having experiences like this,
then looking into people's eyes can become a way of really,
uh,
of,
kind of activating that state of mind where,
you know,
you just being committed to looking into people's eyes and never looking away
can be a way of sort of introducing that sort of liquid psychedelic experience,
you know,
interpersonally.
And I was sort of into that to,
to uh,
uh,
for a while and um,
so I was kind of walking through life,
you know,
like,
like a Tom cruise does basically.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just never just like,
oh,
I'm just going to go with it.
Let's see where this goes and I'm just never going to look away from anyone ever
again.
And you get.
You start having,
I mean it's intrusive and I stopped doing it,
but you,
you start having unusual experiences.
The first thing you do is you discover everyone else is doing that for whatever
reason.
So all of the psychopaths and the scientologists and all,
everyone comes out of the woodwork because there there's some number of people
walking around earth at this moment who are playing that game who are just all.
It's like you look into their eyes and it's just I lock for as long as you're
going to stay and they're never gonna look away and so whether it's a Barista at
starbucks or whether it's just somebody who is,
you know,
50 feet across the room at a party and you make eye contact,
they're not going to be the first one to look away.
And so you get into these really weird encounters.
And I had this.
I remember this one party I went to where I was sitting on a couch and I looked
across the room and there was this guy looking at me and I
probably,
you know,
40 feet between us and he looked at me and I looked at him and then it was just
like war of the warlocks know neither of us were going to look away.
Right.
And it just be that.
And I was doing a lot of meditation and I was uh,
you know,
I had,
it was probably uh,
uh,
taking acid once a month,
you know,
so I was,
I was pretty tuned up for this kind of game where it's just like a,
you know,
I was not,
I had no problem with making eye contact with some strange guy,
you know,
40 feet away.
Um,
and after a certain point he jumped up and kind of raced over to me and know we
had a problem.
He's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And,
and,
and it was like a real,
is what I was doing was so intrusive.
But he,
he had his own game going because he,
you know,
he didn't look away,
right?
He was available for it.
But in any case when you walk through life like this,
you discover that there are a lot of people doing this for,
for whatever reason.
And it's,
it's a.
You definitely have unusual encounters.
Hello Joe,
for Fuck Sake.
Look at you sitting up there and your high.
He asked me if I was David Letterman and tell everybody about this chair.
This is my latest device to try to mitigate back pain from sitting.
And it's called the,
I think it's called a sally.
Yeah.
[inaudible] s a l l I.
and it's a saddle chair.
It's like a saddle.
So if you see how it's sitting here at.
No,
no one's endorsing this.
I'm just telling you it feels I'm going to tell you this.
They would hate me endorsing this because it feels like shit.
It's like the least comfortable chair I think I've ever sat at.
But it's very good for your back and make sure you like,
you can't sit any way other than like this.
Like you have to sit straight up,
you can't slouch in this thing.
It just doesn't support it.
And when I sit in a regular chair by the end of the podcast,
my fucking neck starts to hurt my back.
Like around here where I've been injured,
starts to hurt.
Like stretch your asshole out though.
And like give that to I'm trying to do.
It's easier for me if I ever do wind up going in the pokey.
I want to be just gaping soon.
Um,
no,
it doesn't do anything in your asshole.
You fucking idiot.
You're sitting now.
It's like,
I know this is,
you're not listening.
The whole idea behind this is,
it's like a saddle.
If you sit in the saddle,
you actually kind of have to hold yourself in place.
So by squeezing your legs together,
it's not opening your butthole.
You're actually squeezing everything tight.
So if you were a girl and you wanted to have one of these,
I figured it would probably be good for the ova.
Jj.
Probably tighten that baby up.
Like women are supposed to like do those key not supposed to.
Supposed to.
If they care about trivia penis correctly,
what their vagina,
they do those Qigong exercises where you squeeze your vagina,
you can actually make it stronger.
There's some crazy bitch and Russia that's like the world record holder for the
amount of weight she can carry where they're posting,
but it's something substantial like 50 pounds.
So she shoves a Dildo in her pussy,
attaches it to a fucking Kettlebell and uh,
and does squats holding this,
this Dildo in her,
in her box,
just with their shield pushing back,
like grabbing it like that.
Is anybody else getting hungry?
Yeah.
I don't know why I'm getting peckish you ever hear honeysuckle divine?
Yes.
Yeah.
The one that used to shoot ping pong balls and neither tuna fish sandwich.
No.
Where was that at?
Where did she do?
She did it.
The truck are there in Philadelphia because it was like we were kids.
It was like this big joke about only stuck with the law.
But uh,
I was up at the rib and they were shooting a porn and you know,
these porn girls need so much attention.
Obviously they didn't have anything else to do.
And the more conversation,
so one girl sits in,
the bullet goes do your trick,
you know the,
the container,
their scores put in jams and she just pops it out.
But she paid.
She hit the grill too hard.
It was so funny.
Girls faces there and you go boom.
He's getting the girl goes fuck
big red mark on her face and explained that she can shoot it out of her pussy.
So hard it her.
Yeah,
I can see you doing it.
Vince is fucking up.
Really needs to make you a part of it.
I told Tony when immediately you should do it and I can't believe you didn't
take it Tony because that is the way one of the biggest things for you or for
you because you are that are trying to negotiate doing it part time from La.
That would be awesome.
That would be best for both sides because I wouldn't get burned out on it and
they would have awesome,
great ideas that are hip and cool and I would have been able to do what I want
the pimping cool.
Whenever guy says,
my ideas are hip and cool,
I'll go,
are you sure?
It depends.
What ideas these talking about her as a scarf.
Scarf.
It's a scarf with little skulls all over it.
Like he's a pirate.
He's drinking a Frappaccino
fuck yes.
Undertaker has gone.
Metro,
Metro sexual undertaker.
Maybe if you changed,
all of a sudden Tony starts working for them and every character becomes gay as
good.
Again,
it turns out that there's.
There's someone who's sprinkling gay dust overall.
The other competitors,
whether they're in the locker room,
he's turning.
That's the.
That's a plot that Tony comes up.
He turns the entire roster,
gay.
It turns out there's an openly gay wrestler and he has gay fairy dust.
Okay.
Was he didn't like a leprechauns ball sack,
killed the Leprechaun and turned his ball sack until like this.
Are you ready for this?
What if I were to tell you that there is an openly gay wrestler that blows dust
in people's spaces.
His name is gold dust.
No fucking way.
There he is right there.
Dude.
This is in the wwe.
Dustin Rhodes,
a third generation wrestler.
What's going on with his Dick?
That's gold dust power.
David.
You've heard of horsepower that's related to the dusty roads?
Yeah.
How did you know about Dusty Rhodes?
Eight.
This guy's real pleased.
I need to see more.
I can't believe I invented a guy that already exists.
You should be writing this.
That's him insurance outfit.
When he takes off the wagon robe and he
flirts with them in the ring and Shit blows kisses and they get all riled up and
then he can beat him with shit because they're like,
oh,
not gay.
Get away from me.
And he's like,
oh yeah,
come here.
Beautiful.
And they're lying to the wwe should hire Michael Sam as soon as he's done with
the data
cowboys.
He's the openly gay nfl player.
I don't know.
He's not good enough to make the team it.
Just bring them for the practice squad.
They need to bring that dude into wwe and actually fuck a guy on TV.
Well,
him and gold dust,
but gold does is faking it.
I could tell.
Look it up.
My Guy Straight.
Yeah,
he's super straight.
Is super straight.